And we are again demonstrating to demand an end
immediate rejection and to show
our absolute support for the Palestinian people.
First,
we want to reiterate
the request
the Spanish government to immediately break away from the
diplomatic relations
with Israel.
We do not know
what else has to happen
so that the President of the government and this government
do something concrete
to put an end to the genocide
and to isolate the genocidaires
and to isolate netanyaju
and to isolate Israel.
And we honestly believe
that
recognize the Palestinian state while you are saying
that Israel is a friendly country of Spain
and you do not address the total arms embargo,
that is,
you continue to buy weapons from Israel,
is pure hypocrisy.
It is 1 cosmetic measure
that will not serve to stop the,
to stop the.
Recognizing the Palestinian state
without breaking diplomatic relations with Israel
is 1 cosmetic measure.
It is hypocrisy and will not serve to curb suicide.
Therefore,
we ask you to take concrete measures.
No longer do anything when you can do it
is either hypocrisy or something even worse,
which is complicity.
with.
On the other hand,
as you know,
tonight is the Eurovision final.
In this sense
we want to make 1 strong review radio television
Spanish because it has not positioned itself
against participation
of Israel at the Eurovision Song Contest,
as they have done other public radio and television stations.
in Europe.
"We want to call for the resignation
immediately from the head of the delegation
Eh of the Spanish Radio and Television of the delegation
Spanish at Eurovision.
"We want to ask for your resignation.
"
because I found him months ago
through 1 initiative at City Hall
to ask Israel not to participate in Eurovision.
and they have done absolutely nothing to prevent this
participation.
So we ask for the resignation of Ana María Borás,
the head of the delegation
Spanish Eurovision Song Contest,
and also Di María Izaguirre,
who is the head of communications
and communications
of the Spanish delegation to Eurovision,
who has not demonstrated against Israel
not even after Spanish journalists
have been harassed
by the Israeli press
simply for calling for a cease-fire.
So also
with pain
that we know can cause many Eurofans to
and from admiration
complete nebula
which has already shown us that with music it is possible to
defend freedom
and diversity.
But we believe that the best way than Spain
has to win this Eurovision Song Contest
is not participating in the Eurovision Song Contest.
We need
that everyone can do what they can to stop
this Tuesday.
Then they have also banned Palestine,
the Palestinian flag,
They have banned pennants.
Yes, in fact,
we want to show all of our
recognition and solidarity
both eurofans and eurofans
as well as the artists who are making
protest events at the festival itself,
boycott acts,
even giving up watching 1 festival
that for them and for them
is so valuable,
simply because
There is no one who is doing anything
to prevent participation
of Israel. Therefore,
in front of 1 organization
that is criminalizing
to those who call for the end of the
and that it is protecting the genocides,
we also want to give our
and all our support to these artists and those
eurofans who sometimes with a lot of pain,
are making
acts of protest
to make it clear that Israel is a genocidal state.
and should not participate in Eurovision.
That's what should have happened.
That is why I also understand
the resignation of those responsible for Radiotelevisión
Spanish
who have done nothing to prevent Israel from participating.
And even though we know,
I insist that for many Eurofans it can be painful,
we believe that Spain is the best way to win
this Eurovision Song Contest
is not by participating and not by being an accomplice
of that elabado of Face of Israel
participating in Eurovision